Film Courage: For those writers that do believe in
plot, when it comes to plot, how can
a writer figure out what isn't working?
Tony DuShane, Writer/Podcaster/Teacher:
I think that's in later rewrites,
throw it all in there and then what I do
is I outline more after than I do before
so then I outline the scenes. I want the
scenes to…I kind of think of it as a DJ so
the heavy conflict here is a nine and then let's
get it back down to a four, then let's bring it up
to a seven. I used to DJ at bars and stuff too in
San Francisco with my crates of vinyl [records]. I
want to keep the dance floor going so how do I
keep the dance floor going? I can't smash cut I'm
blanking on Fiona Apple to AC/DC. I probably
can but how do they stay on the dance floor
so then they go buy more drinks so I get more
money at the end of the night from the place.
I think it's about curating the scenes and
then the scene has to make as you get towards
your final draft. The scene has to make a case
for itself. Does the scene even make it into
the movie? I find it really intriguing that this
yes it makes it into the movie yes it gets shot,
yes it gets into post and even those scenes get
cut and and so the there's a reason those scenes
are written even if we have to take them out
when we're in the screenwriting process, there's
a reason those scenes are filmed even if they have
to be taken out during post-production and I don't
know what that reason is and there's probably
producers going we're losing money and when you
do this but at the same time those actors have
to the actor and director have to work through
that scene that never makes it into the movie
but that may inform how another scene is shot
or how a character actor comes at their angle on
another scene and for some I feel like there's no
they're they're there's a lot on the there's
a there's a lot of pages that you wrinkle up
and throw away and you're just like that didn't
work but you need it to get to where it works
you need it you need those and you need to embrace
those pages and you need and just go wow yeah you
almost have to say thank you to the bad writing
because the bad writing gets you to the good stuff
would you play Closing Time at the end of your
DJ sets? I yeah the last I mean I haven't DJ'd
in so many years but the the last ones I did was
I'd throw on a Frank Sinatra or Tom Jones oh wow
after after I've kept the whole Dance Floor going
and it's just kind of like now we're mellowing out
we're bringing it down okay so yes the bartenders
are trying to do all their work to clean up and
it's the last call ding last call I'm just like
so in a movie though you're also you're you're
winding down the audience whether it's a yes wind
down or or a sad one or in some foreign film sort
of an ambiguous ending where we don't really know
right when it comes to plot and then the wind down
happens and we're a few minutes from the end is
there really a bad ending is there an ending that
this is not textbook how it should have been if
it's a happy story sad whatever yeah it's I think
I'm trying to there's there's a film I just
watched where I was like oh that ending was
so horrible I can't remember what film
it was darn it and it was a good film
there's a lot of films I really love
and I'm like oh you blew in the ending
and but as far as like as far as the stakes of act
three and the stakes of the high tension and then
we need the brat we all need to sit in it we all
kind of need to sit and relax and go wow and we
have to do that with the characters on the screen
and with everyone there's a there's a movie that
I bring to class especially my beginning classes
I make everyone and I've watched this hundreds of
times because I make everyone completely dissect
every single scene in it it's Little Miss Sunshine
and Little Miss Sunshine I actually have the I
get the DVDs in the movies because I don't like
so I'm the DVD collector but they also have the
extras on there and they have the deleted scenes
and there was like one or two extra scenes at
the end of the movie that they completely shot
where there was like where they're like well that
was crazy they're they're another like an a rest
stop and they're all on a bench and they're all
talking everything's just gone great and said oh
what do you want a hamburger and they shot this
whole scene but the end of the movie is the bus
driving away and it's the some people sometimes
you don't know what the end of the movie is until
it's way in post-production and and they didn't
know they thought they needed these tagons they
there's there's a lot of times where filmmakers
feel like they need to to hold the hand of the
audience a little more and the audience can hold
their own handle a lot of times the audience can
get it we don't have to we don't have to
kind of push it on them now feel like this
it's just like no stop that that was good enough
you're fine take a breath and think about that
I like that is do you think that just only comes
from seeing the actors play out that scene that
it's hard to tell on the page I don't know if it's
hard yeah it could be hard to tell on the page and
we're just trying to write the best story we
can with it's funny so with Confessions of a
Teenage Jesus Jerk [Tony’s book] I was from the
final draft I was very adamant about the ending
and I was like this is the ending this is
it and and there was a scene that was asked
to for afterwards and I'm just like no I didn't
want to write it and I and it had to be written
and then they shot it and then it didn't make the
film it didn't make the final cut and for some odd
reason maybe it did need to be shot so maybe maybe
I I've done so many things wrong and my Approach
has been sometimes my Approach isn't the greatest
approach sometimes I could be a little friendlier
and a little more amicable and go oh you're
right let's just do that and see what happens
but with this I was so sure that that was the end
but the the people involved weren't sure and it's
okay that they're not sure and so just let people
not be sure and then pray and post that it all
works out and and it may have been that depending
on how the tone of the film went because when that
edit when it's in the editing room it's being the
whole story is being told again by an editor so
they may have needed to get that on camera just in
case they kept different scenes in there or they
had to lose scenes and but to get the whole tone
of the film they went nope that was the ending
so there's there's so many elements to how to end
a movie I mean I guess there it's and so much of
that stake so on the page the best you can do and
then does it end up in the final cut who knows
because there's so many there's so many factors
involved so so that's interesting you you resisted
sort of the suggested ending they wanted an
extra scene at the end and then it ended up
not happening and you ended up agreeing that that
was actually a good thing to have that extra scene
no no they shot the scene and and then but but I
won and then I won because they that scene hit the
cutting room floor so the movie ended exactly as
I wanted it to end does that make sense yeah and
I wasn't sure if you wanted the cutting room floor
one you actually agreed with them oh okay no no I
still I did I still didn't agree and when I when I
was sent the rough cut as I was coming to the end
I was going yeah the I had to cut to black it
was cut to black I'm like cut to black cut to
black got the black and a boom cut to black and
I was like yes so it was and there were and there
were other battles that I had where I was like
okay this is right and you don't go and then
and I was totally wrong and so it's there's that's
the beauty of the the collaboration of have those
disagreements because as the writer oh yeah I
can like pretend like I know everything but I
don't once you what's your once you're on set what
you're with a director once you're seeing actors
it's it's you you really got to kind of let things
go and yeah the only thing I was so I was really
adamant about was how the how it was going to
end and I just I saw that from the beginning and
and it wasn't it didn't make anyone feel
comfortable so maybe everyone needed to
feel comfortable and then they went no wait
that's right the ending is the cut to black.